SERGEI SOKOLENKO:
The next 60 minutes
will be about serverless
data processing.
Just to give you a bit
of an overview of what
we will be reviewing today
or looking at-- we'll
quickly go over some of
the technical benefits
of Cloud Dataflow.
This is a level 300 session.
So we'll skip most
of the basic stuff
and just we'll provide
some overview but dive deep
into the technical
benefits pretty quickly.
I will do a demo
of a new feature
that we launched
just last month--
data flow templates.
It will show you how easy
it is to do data processing
without operating any servers
and launching pipelines
without any servers.
I'll then deep dive into
two particular benefits
of Cloud Dataflow.
Specifically, dynamic load
balancing and autoscaling.
I'll do a demo of auto
scaling and show you
the history of autoscaling
for a particular pipeline
that I will launch.
I'll call Ankur to
and here is going
to talk about how
Brightcove is using
Cloud Dataflow and
several other UCP products
to provide video analytics
to their customers.
We will have a recap and
also do a Q&A. If you
would like to ask questions,
we have two microphones
in the aisles.
So at the Q&A session just
come up and feel free to ask.
So most of the
customers, before they
start using Cloud
Dataflow, they use
something that is called
a lambda architecture.
A collection of tools,
Abobe Spark, Kafka,
which is optimized for
specific flows of data
for batch processing and
for steaming processing.
Once our customers are
switching to data flow,
they take advantage
of a unified model.
This is one of the major
reasons why customers are
migrating to Cloud Dataflow--
it offers a unified way of
doing batch and steaming,
and you can use
it in conjunction
with other GCP-assisted products
such as Pub/Sub and BigQuery
to build your data
processing pipelines.
If you're a fan of open-source
computing-- and who isn't--
you can also use Cloud Dataflow
with another stack of data
processing applications.
We have open-sourced
our SDK and it
became Apache Beam, which
just recently became
a top-level Apache project.
And you can use beam
runners on a variety--
in a variety of environments,
including Spark, Fling,
and some others.
To summarize, why customers
are using Cloud Dataflow.
By the way, just
by a show of hands,
who has already been able to
run a few data flow pipelines?
OK good.
Maybe a third, a
quarter of the audience.
So Cloud Dataflow
offers you a unified way
of doing batch and steaming.
You get access to a fully
managed environment,
so you can spend your time
on optimizing your pipeline
code instead of running and
managing server infrastructure.
We offer you a open-source
programming model,
so you are not locked
in to just one vendor.
You can run Beam pipelines
in Cloud Dataflow,
or you can run and--
run it on premises
or other cloud
providers with other runners
such as Spark and Flint.
And we are also able
to scale from maybe 10
records per second
incoming data stream
to millions of
records per second.
Architecturally, here's
an architechtural overview
of Cloud Dataflow.
We are a black box that
connects sources and sinks.
We support streaming
and batch sources.
We call them
bounded-unbounded sources,
and we write into
a variety of sinks.
So we offer connectors
for sources and sinks.
We also offer a bunch of
benefits under the hood,
including-- the create the
worker VMs for you will,
which actually execute
and run your code.
We optimize the pipelines
that you submit to us.
You can keep kind of thinking
at a more abstract level.
And if you are a SQL programmer,
think about writing a SQL query
and then submitting
it to a database
and we do the
optimizations for you.
We scale resources
for you, up and down,
depending on the workload.
And we do a redistribution
of work between workers when
particular workers become hot.
I'm going to talk about
two specific benefits later
in my presentation.
But that was an overview
of all the benefits
that Dataflow provides.
If you are a developer, then
from a developer's point
of view you write pipeline code.
We support multiple languages--
Java and Python.
This code has access to a wide
variety of data transformation
functions in our SDKs.
The SDKs are
language independent,
so they offer the
same functionality
in both Java and Python.
We call it the Beam model.
Beam provides abstractions.
For example, if you
want to do parallel--
to the process data
elements in parallel.
You can use a
transform called ParDo.
We call ParDos the--
our transform for
parallel processing.
If you want to group things
by key in any language--
Java or Python, you use
a group by key transform.
And as I already mentioned,
once you wrote your pipeline
and kind of chose your
language-- your SDK--
you can run it in a
variety of runners.
You can run it in
Cloud Dataflow.
You can run it in Spark,
and you can run it in Flint.
So I wanted to highlight four
specific technical benefits
of Cloud Dataflow before
I do my first demo.
I already mentioned the
full management aspect
of Cloud Dataflow.
We create workers for you.
We allocate-- we split your
data inputs into smaller shards,
and allocate them to workers.
We also do optimizations
of your execution code.
For example, you might
start with a pipeline,
and pipelines can be
thought of activity diagrams
where you have bubbles of
transformations and data
flowing from one
transformation bubble
to the next
transformation bubble.
So you think in terms of
these activity diagrams.
And what you want
to do with data,
you define your transforms
and you connect them.
You submit your
pipeline graphs to us
and we optimize the execution.
Sometimes we will
merge steps together
if we think that it will
be more efficient to do
both transformations together.
Sometimes we split them up
to achieve a higher level
of parallelism.
Yet another benefit of Cloud
Dataflow is autoscaling.
So think about a
workload which maybe
starts with just 800 records
per second incoming data stream.
It's the beginning of
the day, your users
are not doing much,
so just generating
about 8,000 records per second.
We'll allocate just
a sufficient number
of workers which are required
to process in incoming work
stream.
Now during the day,
your users will
begin submitting more events.
It might reach
several thousand--
5,000 in this example.
Through autoscaling,
Cloud Dataflow
is able to sense the increase
in CPU utilization, the increase
in incoming data rates, and
increase the number of workers
automatically a much
training number.
Not only do we increase
the number of workers,
we also decrease them.
And the workload is--
when your incoming data
stream is declining.
And lastly, the last feature
I wanted to highlight.
The are the two features--
autoscaling and dynamic load
rebalancing-- which I
wanted to kind of deep dive
a little bit later.
It's important that I cover
them on a higher level first.
Is dynamic work rebalancing.
I already mentioned that when
you tell us your data inputs
and let us allocate the workers
to process these data inputs,
some of the data shards
which we create--
data shards of your input data--
might contain data which
takes longer to process
than all the other shards.
We call such shards stragglers.
And sometimes-- well
actually, quite often--
because of the
existence of stragglers,
your entire data
pipeline will take longer
to execute because
we are waiting
for the completion
of the straggler.
With this feature that we
have, dynamic work rebalancing,
we are actually able to
steal, take away work
from the worker
which is struggling
and reallocate it
to other workers.
Now I will show it in a demo,
which I want to do just now.
Can we switch to the
demo show, please.
First, in the demo
I'm going to start
with showing you how easy it is
to start a data flow pipeline.
We have recently
launched a feature
called Dataflow Templates.
Templates allow you to
write your pipeline,
deposit it into a GCS bucket,
and then call on this code
whenever you would like and
wherever you would like.
You can initiate this
template from the console.
template into a data flow job
from GCloud or through the API.
In my demo I'm going to use a
export off a publicly available
data set of Hacker News.
Those of you who know
me, know that I am very
excited about text analytics.
I love natural
language processing.
I write algorithms for
crunching through news articles,
trying to extract
opinions from text.
So I took the--
I took one of the public
data sets that we have,
Hacker News news posts, and
dumped them into a bunch
of .csv files for this demo.
As you can see in this GCS
bucket where I dumped my Hacker
News data set, I have about
30 or 40 .csv files of a size
of about 125 megabytes.
But one particular
file is extra long,
and you'll see why
it's important.
This file, a very large file
.csv is 5.5 gigabytes long.
And those are the stragglers
I'm talking about.
Sometimes your data
is just larger--
your data shards are larger
than other data shards.
So let me started my
Dataflow pipeline.
I'm going to go to the Dataflow
console and click on run job.
In this new UI, you are able
to choose which template
you would like to instantiate.
Some of the options are--
I can do a custom template.
Custom template is the code
that you write and place in GCS.
And you can then
share it with others
and stantiate it into
Dataflow jobs, etc.
I will actually use
a simple algorithm
that we typically do for--
typically share with
customers when they
start learning about data flow.
It's the word count algorithm.
It's quite simple.
It reads from text files,
counts the number of words,
and then does statistics
on these words.
I'll give the job a name--
demojob01, and
specify my input--
GCS bucket.
I'll use a pattern to catch all
the .csv files in this bucket.
And lastly, I will also
specify my output bucket
where the text statistics
should eventually end up.
That's all I needed to do
to launch a data processing
pipeline.
I didn't have to
install any IDEs,
I didn't have to launch VMs.
I can basically
launch now pipelines
through the console using
the templating mechanism.
And within seconds,
Dataflow will
start showing you the execution
steps of this pipeline.
As I mentioned before,
it's relatively simple.
It reads lines from
my input files.
It runs the text
calculation algorithms.
It does some mapping work,
and then it [INAUDIBLE]
into GCS files.
I will come back to this
pipeline in about 10 minutes,
to show you a couple
of other things
that I will continue talking
about during my presentation.
Slides please.
So this is the code
of the pipeline.
Reading from files,
applying a data transform
to calculate statistics
on text, in parallel form
of the outputs, and
writing back into files.
Because Cloud Dataflow is
a parallel data processing
service, we offer you
as a user the ability
to run your transformation--
data transformations
in parallel.
And we call these
capabilities ParDos.
So basically, define
a transform function,
we call them Do functions--
DoFuns-- and then
you tell the ParDo
transform to go and
execute your Do function.
The Do function takes
data in a certain shape--
in this diagram it is
represented by yellow bricks
or yellow squares--
and reshapes them into data
elements of a different shape.
Maybe adds additional fields,
removes them, aggregates them.
Again in the diagram,
represented as green stars.
Since Cloud Dataflow is a
parallel data processing
service, we run many,
many workers that do--
that execute your transforms.
The best way of visualizing
what your workers are doing--
your worker virtual
machines are doing
is to display a Gantt chart.
In my diagram here, I have eight
workers working on data shards.
Data shards are my--
is my input data set that I
subdivided into smaller chunks.
So these eight workers
take a data shard.
They work on it,
they complete it,
and they start working
on the next shard.
Here's a real-life Gantt
chart of a data flow pipeline
of 400 workers running for about
20 minutes doing three things.
It reads files, it then does
a group by key operation.
And this is why you see this
way-- a clean separation
between stages.
First it needs to
read the files.
Once it has the
entire data set, it
begins grouping data by keys.
And it also writes into files.
With parallel data
processing, one
of the big problems
that I mentioned before
is the presence of stragglers.
And stragglers are
really your data shards
which take longer to execute
than the average execution
time for all the other data
shards of your data set.
In this diagram here, stragglers
would be the bar in red,
and the yellow one is kind
of approaching the cutoff.
Where do stragglers come from?
And this is important, because
if we want to provide you
a service which does--
minimizes the resources
that we utilize,
that improves the execution
performance of your data
pipelines, we need to be
able to detect stragglers
and we need to be able
to deal with them.
So the first step
here is to understand
where they could come from.
They could be coming from
an uneven distribution
of your input data.
For example, if
your input data sets
are textual files and speak
your favorite language--
let's say English.
English has a natural
skewed data distribution
to the frequency
of words starting
with a particular letter.
So all the data shards
which contain words
starting with a T, for
example, will be longer
than other data shards.
Where else do data shards--
stragglers come from?
Well for example, if
you do a join operation
and you have to--
you have two input data sets.
And you are trying to join
each key on the left hand side,
with the responding keys
on the right hand side.
For some of the
keys on the left--
I'm using the left-right
terminology in joins--
some of the keys on the left,
you will have many more records
on the right.
And this is again another reason
you could have stragglers.
Not only does the data or--
yes, data could kind
of lead to straddlers.
You can sometimes also have
issues with the infrastructure.
And you can have issues
with networking, or perhaps
a slow desk.
Something is going on
with the OS or the VM.
There are not enough resources
on a particular virtual machine
that runs your code to
process data quickly.
It's yet another reason
for data stragglers.
What could you do to
address this issue?
Well you could start splitting
your input data into yet--
a high number of shards.
That might help in some cases.
You can try to
alert your users--
you being the vendor of a
data processing service.
You could let your users
define business rules
and try to kind of fine tune
how many workers are allocated
to each shards
which of the workers
are being allocated to
the shards, and so on.
That's a little complex,
but can be done.
You could collect
statistics on data
before the execution
of the pipeline,
and create and start your
stragglers first, for example,
so that they can
complete faster.
On the hardware side, or
the infrastructure side--
this is especially something
that folks in the Hadoop world
do--
could do backups and restarts,
which help with this problem.
Well at Cloud Dataflow,
we spend a lot
of time thinking
about these problems.
And we deal with them by
first detecting stragglers
and fighting.
Fighting meaning dealing
with this problem.
So the first step is
to identify stragglers.
So what do we do?
For each of the shards,
and each of the workers
which process these
shards, we always
track the estimated
completion time.
We always estimate
how long it will
take to finish the processing
of an active shard.
And when we see that
the expected completion
time exceeds the
average completion
time for all the other
shards, we raise a flag.
This is a indicator for us--
this shard will
become a straggler
and will slow down the pipeline.
So what do we do?
We split them up.
Splitting up means we
ask the worker which
is responsible for processing
these stragglers to give back
some of the work that
they are responsible for.
The giving back
could consist from,
give me a range of line
items in your input data set.
Give me a particular
IDs in your input data
set that you are unable
to process quickly,
so that I can reallocate
it to other workers.
So we continuously do that.
And in my diagram
here, the green bars
represent work that
is already completed.
I have eight workers, have
already done nine shards.
The fourth worker
devoted to [INAUDIBLE].
The yellow bars represent the
shards they are currently,
actively working on
and the beige bars
represent the estimated
completion time.
And for each of these
shards, we have calculated
the estimated completion time
and we detected for two of them
that they will be late.
And so we will try to
allocate the work--
we will not try, we will
reallocate the work.
We will take away
work from these shards
and reassign it
to other workers.
Not only do it do it do it
once during the execution
of the pipeline, we
do this repeatedly.
And here's what it
actually leads to.
Going back to my example
of a real-life pipeline--
it's actually an example
I haven't shown yet.
The pipeline is a relatively
simple transformation.
It does only one type of
transformation on your data,
and it runs on 24 workers.
I'm talking about the diagram
in the upper left quadrant here.
So 24 workers trying to do a
very simple transformation,
a very simple ParDo.
But there's a skewed
data distribution,
and two of these shards will
take much longer than the rest.
Without load rebalancing, the
execution of this pipeline
will take nine minutes.
But look what load rebalancing
did to this pipeline.
It reduced the execution
time almost 50%,
to about four minutes
and 20 seconds.
And look how much more
utilized your workers are now.
They complete at
approximately the same time.
Here's another
example of a pipeline
that I mentioned previously.
400 workers doing somewhat
more involved transformations.
A read ParDo, so
reading from files.
Doing a group by key,
writing to files.
The data is not the problem--
data is uniformly distributed.
But there is still a
bit of lag between some
of the workers in
the reading part
and some of the variation in
the workers in the writing part.
Without load rebalancing, the
pipeline takes 20 minutes.
With load rebalancing,
the savings are not huge,
but they are nice 25%.
Utilization is
significantly higher,
and we've reduced
all the slack--
all the white space
between the workers.
Dynamic load balancing
is great in isolation,
but it is especially
is useful when
you start thinking
about adjusting
your workload to the variations
in the incoming data stream.
What we call autoscale.
Think about a case where you
start with three workers.
That's my diagram up
in the first row here.
So three workers working
on several data shards.
And for the first
couple of minutes,
since we are doing estimation
of the completion time,
everything looks fine.
It looks like we can process
the data within 10 minutes.
Not a big deal.
But as time progresses, and
as data flow is consistently
and continuously re-estimating
the completion time,
we learn more about
the input data sets.
We begin sensing that the actual
completion will be much longer.
The first couple of records in
our data charts were atypical,
and the average record
in our data shard
will cause the pipeline
to take 3 days.
Great.
So we realize we
could definitely
use some additional help.
Why don't we start 100
new workers and crunch
through the data just by
throwing more CPU on it?
Well we could.
But if you don't
have the ability
to divide the work of a
live-running pipeline,
your additional
workers will be idle.
There will be nothing
for them to do.
So without this ability
to dynamically reassign
work and re-balance work,
autoscaling just doesn't work.
And here's a diagram.
Here is a screenshot of another
real-life pipeline, which
starts with three
workers and kind of keeps
learning about the properties
of your input data.
And realizes we can process--
we can process the
pipeline faster
if we added more workers.
And its great that we have the
ability to divide the work,
so we launch new workers.
We allocate work to them.
Every worker is working hard,
there is no white space.
They are fully utilized.
Eventually, a pipeline
reaches thousands of workers.
It crunches the
data and completes
and then scales
down, shuts down.
Let me show you how exactly
autoscaling is benefiting you
on the example of my pipeline
that I just recently launched.
Demo machines please.
All right.
So here is my pipeline,
back to my pipeline.
It completed within
about eight minutes.
The reason why I
know it's completed
is the green check boxes in each
of the transformation steps,
for those of you
who haven't seen
the Dataflow console before.
One interesting feature that
we have in the Google Console--
Google Dataflow
console-- is the history
of autoscaling decisions.
So check it out
when you go back,
if you haven't seen it yet.
Here's the full history of
what went on in your pipeline.
Read from the bottom-- read
from the bottom of the screen.
We started with a pool
of a single worker.
And remember, I
had about 40 files
in my data set of
approximately the same size,
with the exception of one file
which was 50 times longer--
50 times larger-- than
all the other files.
So the data flow kept
re-estimating and reallocating
workers.
It increased the number of
workers to two, then 8, to 15.
And 15 seemed to be a good
balance of number of workers
and available data inputs.
So we kept working at that
level until we process all
the records and then shut down.
Hopefully this was a
useful demonstration
of the capabilities of
dynamic load rebalancing
and autoscaling.
And with this I
would like to invite
Ankur Chauhan from Brightcove
to talk about how Brightcove is
using Dataflow at Brightcove.
Can we go back to
the slides please?
ANKUR CHAUHAN: Thanks Sergei.
Hello everyone.
I am-- hello everyone.
I'm Ankur Chauhan
from Brightcove.
I am a software engineer with
the video analytics team.
Brightcove is an online video
platform which provides video--
end-to-end video services to
companies large and small.
They're supposed to be
Snapchat over there,
but it kept on disappearing
after 10 seconds.
[LAUGHTER]
So we provide video analytics
to companies big and small,
which means that we
handle lots of data.
We deliver about 8,500
years of video every month,
which generates about
seven billion events a day.
Which generates a
lot of time series.
But because we believe
that raw data just
crunched up together and
summed up is not useful,
we aggregate it down to about
80 million unique time series.
And all this is maintained by a
pretty small team of engineers,
about five or six of us.
So basically half
of the team is here.
So as Sergei pointed out, we
followed a pretty traditional
approach.
We went with a lambda model.
So as you can see,
the top part is
optimized for
streaming calculation,
whereas the lower part is
more of a batch system.
Events come in through the
top from our web players
and Roku devices and
Android devices and iPhones.
And they come to our
beacon over SCDP,
get aggregated in real
time and stored away
into the real-time database.
At the same time,
we write all of this
down into logs and store--
and store it to S3 so
that we can aggregate it
every few hours.
Because one of the deals that
you make with the lambda model
is that the streaming
system is really
optimized for, well,
being real-time.
And that means that it is lossy.
So to take care of that, we
have a reconciled database
which goes in every few hours
and happily churns through all
the logs and gives it to
a reconciled database.
And the API comes along for
every API request and says,
hey, give me the
data for this request
that the user is trying to make.
It merges the two data sets
and gives it to the user.
On the side we have
a red-shift database,
and over that we have
some BI tools written.
So if anyone knows the work
that goes into managing a lambda
model system and
everything, they
would know that it's
a little latent.
Hadoop takes a lot of time
to churn through data.
You don't absolutely get all
your results immediately.
Plus, there are more or
less two code bases here.
So every so often we would get
a support ticket which says,
hey, my result from yesterday
doesn't match the result
from today.
Or, why is this ever
so slightly different?
So there is always
pain for that.
So all this is working fine,
and for many years it did.
And then things happen.
The most important
one is Brightcove
is a growing company.
And more people come online and
they watch more video, which
means that we have more scale.
We are adding more disks.
We are adding more compute nodes
to our Hadoop cluster, which
is now bursting at its seams.
So we are spending
more and more time
just keeping the
lights on, essentially,
which means that lesser and
lesser features get delivered.
So we had to do
something about that.
But even more
important is that there
were some new features
in line, specifically
session collation, which we
thought was really important.
Session collation
basically means
that we had to look at a
viewing session in its entirety.
It's a much more
resource-intensive thing
to do and Hadoop and the
home-grown streaming system
was just not cutting it.
It was a lot of work and we
wanted to get something better.
At the same time, we wanted to
use a more performing execution
engine which could support
all this and the future things
that we wanted to do.
As well as a more robust and
performance database layer
which could take
care of all this.
So we went, we did our research.
And we found that everyone
seemed to recommend
these slew of technologies.
They're pretty
amazing technologies.
They are open source,
so you can actually
see the source of
the product, and you
can figure out whether
they actually wrote
the tests that they did.
They are performing.
They have big
communities behind them.
So you know that
if you get stuck
you will have some
one to turn to,
and hopefully they will be
able to answer your questions.
So Kafka, Spark, Cassandra,
Hadoop, Mesos, all good.
And we were like, Yeah,
lets do this, sit down.
So we started planning.
And within the first
15 minutes of planning,
you know, beep, beep, beep.
Pagers going off in our heads.
This is a lot of
systems to manage.
And with five people,
we would essentially
be just managing these systems.
And we had to, first
of all, become experts
at these systems.
To run them, establish them,
build monitoring resources
for them-- so
dashboards and alerts.
And then each of these systems
have like 500 variables
to tune just right
to get them working
in the right way we want them.
So it's not easy.
So we were like, OK, need to
step back, look at this again.
So the basic theory in this
architecture is very sound.
You have a simple thing
that you're trying to do.
Event collector goes
to a message queue
which goes to some
computation thing
and gets written to a database.
And you want to write
it to a warehouse
and finally serve it out.
But each of these
components are very heavy,
so we wanted to sort
of make them lighter.
And what we wanted
to do was look
for some managed
solutions for this,
for each part of the system.
So that with the
five-person team
we actually manage
less and do more.
So.
Looked around, and
lots of claims,
lots of marketing material.
But if you're an
engineer, you're
taught one thing for sure--
trust but verify.
Never trust a marketing
material or a blog post
just because it says 100%
managed and performant.
So we went out and we wrote
lots of performance tests.
We did our due
diligence in making sure
that we could swap every
component individually
without sort of getting
locked into the wrong thing.
And we went step-by-step to
make sure that we got it right.
So easy pass-- easy parts first.
We saw Google and we saw
Google Container Engine.
Best way to deploy applications,
so we went with it.
We deployed our micro services
for the API on top of GKE.
Straightforward.
We knew how to do it.
Run some-- there are lots
of resources to help us out,
and it's Kubernetes,
so even more community.
So that was perfect.
Next we went with how
to deal with Kafka.
Kafka has this magical
dependency called Zookeeper.
Which if you have
managed it, it's
just completely magical in
terms of just going down
for no apparent reason.
So we didn't want
to deal with it.
And what we found
was that Pub/Sub was
a very good replacement for it.
It is a globally available
and durable message queue.
Which means that all
the work that we would
have to do in terms of
keeping replicas alive
and making sure the
Kafka is properly
provisioned for our scale and is
all good, we don't have to do.
So three months saved.
Message de-duplication by ID.
So you can, with the Pub/Sub
and Dataflow working together,
you can actually deliver
messages again and again
and assign them a unique ID.
And Dataflow will make sure
that it processes that message
just once.
So exactly once.
And, finally, because
it's globally available,
very little chance that
you get disconnected
from every single region of
Google everywhere in the world.
Pretty much not going to happen.
So great.
Next thing that we looked
at was our database
it's the single most pinpoint
operational burden of our team.
We have spent weeks, sometimes,
just bringing the system up.
So we wanted to find
a solution to it.
Our data set is
time series based.
So Bigtable-- Cassandra
was our first choice.
And then we looked around and
we saw Bigtable was there.
And if you read
the Cassandra docs,
one of the inspirations
for Cassandra
is the Bigtable table.
So we were like, OK, Google
knows what it's doing.
It's a pretty well-respected
people, so let's check it out.
We wrote our performance
tests and it just
blew past everything
that we thought.
In addition to that, it's
one button scale up and down.
So go into the console.
You said the number of nodes
to 30 and save and it's done.
And it provides
the interface using
the good old Edge-based APIs, so
there's lots of tooling for it
and it works very well.
Very reliable and performant.
So database, another one.
It's the easy button.
And finally ad hoc analysis
and doing [INAUDIBLE] things.
At our scale, we get
terabytes of data every day.
So sooner or later a support
call will come in which says,
hey, can you find this absurd
thing from your data set?
And we wanted to
answer that question.
And in the past, whenever
we had to do that
it was a couple of
days of going to S3
and downloading a
whole bunch of logs,
running it through grep or
some other tool that we wrote,
and giving the answer.
If you have used
BigQuery, you'll
know how easy it is to
actually run queries in it.
It's a console, you write
the SQL query and it's done.
It's almost as cheap as
just storing files in S3.
And it's completely
managed and it
churns through
terabytes in seconds,
so immediate win for us.
Things that used to take days
for us to debug and diagnose
took maybe five
minutes, at best.
Elephant in the room.
Spark and Hadoop.
It's a monster system
because it's trying
to solve a monster problem.
But it's something that
we wanted to tackle.
So we again looked around,
and just at this time
Google Dataflow had
come out of beta.
So-- sorry, come into beta.
So we looked at it, we read
the paper that was published.
We read some blog posts
and we read some docs
and we liked every single thing.
It was right there, and
we trusted none of it.
Followed by, we went in, and
we wrote a proof of concept
over a hackathon.
And two days later,
we were like--
50% of our feature set
was implemented in it.
Which was great.
So we sat down and
looked at it even more.
For the first time, I think
it provides a unified batch
and streaming model.
The Beam model is very powerful.
So you don't have to maintain
two almost identical code
bases just to do the same
thing, which is a big win.
Streaming reconciliation,
which means
that whenever a message
gets picked up off Pub/Sub,
you know that it's
going to get written.
It's guaranteed to get done.
And you don't have to do
anything of the sort of retries
and all of those things.
And finally, its
batteries included.
What I mean by that is
it comes with a slew
of inputs and outputs,
of sources and sinks.
So you don't have
to implement them.
Those is text input,
which Sergei used.
There's Pub/Sub, and on the
output side we use Bigtable,
but there's BigQuery,
text output, many others.
And lots of windowing operators.
So, we want to do
session collation,
we have to essentially say
window by session, and done.
So, immediate win for
us and we were already
one year ahead in our game of
implementing all this stuff.
Which just great.
So putting it back into our
original architecture diagram.
Everything inside the
dotted box over there
is a managed service.
What that means is
that we would never
get a page for those services.
Which also means that
someone in Google,
who is very well
trained for that job,
knows how to diagnose, debug,
and fix those services when
they do go wrong.
And it's a much
more linear system,
which means that when
things are not working
or when we want to
develop something,
we know exactly
where to point at.
We know what to tweak.
We know how to reason
about it, which
makes everyone's life easier.
So what did this give us?
Less pain, more features.
Faster.
And if you look on
the side, we now
have another box which is BI
tools and ad hoc Analysis.
So we got more stuff
done because we
were able to get access
to tools which had
much lower marginal cost to us.
There's no thinking
around, this query
is going to take eight days
to run, so let me not do it.
You just go in, run the
BigQuery query, get your answer,
get on with life.
All of this took about six
months to sort of perfect
and get it right.
There were lots of
lessons learned.
And if some of you have managed
Hadoop, a lot of that knowledge
transfers over.
Specifically, if
you want to speed up
your data flow or
your processing,
the best way to do it
is process less data.
Reduce your I/O. Use a better
desk, namely a SSD disk.
They are much faster.
You'll get a performance
boost without doing anything.
Secondly is use a schema
data interchange format.
Protobuf is a great one.
We started with JSON.
JSON is great when
you're just starting out.
It lets you tweak and
twiddle with stuff,
but it's not optimized
for machines.
That means a lot of your
compute is just spent
serializing-deserializing.
And in addition to that, you
would spend a lot of time
just cleaning up the data.
So you'll write
tons of code just
to make sure that the
right fields are present,
the right format is
there, or something
or the other in the same thing.
So we use protobuf and we
like it and it provides
many, many features, some of
them being it is efficient
and backwards compatibility.
Finally, being from an
analytics background,
I cannot stress this
enough-- monitor everything.
What makes sense
for our workload,
CPU, and Pub/Sub backlog may
not make sense for yours.
You might have a completely
different set of metrics
which makes sense to you.
So monitor them.
We make lots of
dashboards so that we
have visibility into
everything, and that's
worked out very well for us.
And finally, when all
fails, you get stuck.
There is a data
flow team, which was
very eager to help us out in--
on every turn.
So we really liked the team.
And then, before I go
into a short little demo,
this is a future roadmap which
I would not be showing you here
at all had we been implementing
all this stuff using
Spark and Hadoop.
Adaptive aggregates.
So we analyze our
customers' request
volume and their
request patterns
and automatically adjust
how we aggregate our data.
So their queries
magically become faster.
Lot more BI tools.
We have started to build
a lot more BI tools on top
of BigQuery, which give us--
which give our
internal customers
much more visibility into
data which just wasn't there.
And finally, and it's
a big one, that we
are able to unify our analytics
and billing pipelines.
Because there is
a hard guarantee
that your data, once it's
acknowledged, actually gets
saved to our database.
We can be sure that
it's good enough--
good enough that
that data exists.
So the billing system can trust
this data analytics system.
Our previous analytics
system always had this thing
that the billing data was
ever so slightly different.
So we would trust
the billing and there
would be questions
about it, like, why
is it slightly different?
And we would have to explain.
No longer.
So that's great.
Everyone's happy.
Everyone is joyous.
So, with that, I'll show you
what our pipeline actually
looks like.
This is-- I'm going to cheat
a little bit because demo gods
are never great during demos.
So this is a video of the
same Google Cloud Console
of our production pipeline.
As you can see, we are reading
from two Pub/Sub topics
at the top, performing a
bunch of computations on them,
and churning through
data constantly.
And then finally writing
it back to do Bigtable.
The amazing thing here
for me is that it's
a very simple representation
of a complex piece of software.
Each box directly lines
up with a piece of code
that we have written.
So even though data flow
underneath the covers
is performing all these
optimizations of--
all different sorts
of optimizations,
we don't have to do those.
And that's amazing.
And we can just concentrate
on how things look like.
So that was how our
pipeline looks like.
And next we have--
next we have the
monitoring dashboard.
So our main intuition
behind making this dashboard
is keeping it simple.
So that when you wake up at
3:00 AM because of a page--
first of all, the block color
does not hurt your eyes.
The second part
is that everything
is exactly what you need.
And so the first row
is Pub/Sub metrics.
For us, Pub/Sub backlog
is a good indicator
of how we're doing.
So when, you know,
there's a sudden increase
in messages published to us, and
data flow starts falling behind
and it doesn't keep
up for some threshold,
let's say three hours.
We get an alert saying,
hey, go look at Pub/Sub.
Or go look at the Dataflow
it's not keeping up.
We come here and we see that,
OK, message volume increased.
Pub/Sub is backed up
because Dataflow is churning
through it, it'll be good.
Just leave it.
If it is auto-scaled, it will
scale up, process everything,
scale down.
Everyone's fine.
The CPU utilization
we monitor that just
to make sure that we know that
we are spending the exact right
amount of money.
We want to keep these machines
as utilized as possible,
but not so much that
they are all overwhelmed.
And low CPU is generally
a good indicator
that the pipeline just
seized up for some reason,
needs some more work.
So, to the point,
monitoring that
helps you go back to sleep.
And with that, I will hand
the mike back to Sergei.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEI SOKOLENKO: Thanks, Ankur.
So let's recap.
We took a look at how easy it
is to launch Dataflow pipelines
using Dataflow Templates.
We deep dived into two
specific technical benefits
of Cloud Dataflow-- dynamic load
rebalancing and auto-scaling.
And we also heard
from Brightcove.
How easy it was to
build a video analytics
solution using Dataflow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]